everybody
a rare sight for these voters in Rio de
Janeiro a presidential candidate
campaigning in a place dominated by drug
traffickers and violence
just four months ago 20 people were
killed during a police raid here in the
complex a sprawling brick and cement
network of favelas or slums leftist
former leader luisi nasu Lula da Silva
promised that their lives would change
as they had during his last presidential
term
I doubt that you will find any
construction from incumbent president
Yaya bolsonaro here or in any Favela in
the state
but even people who benefited from
social projects during Lula's presidency
more than 10 years ago and moved from
Shacks to these government-built
departments are divided
we don't believe in promises president
bosnare has promised nothing but has
given emergency aid to face the pandemic
and the consequences of the war in
Ukraine
I voted for bolsonaro in 2018 because
the economy was in the dumps I changed
my vote to Lula after I survived a heart
attack this year thanks to the public
hospital he built next to my house
remembers how life changed after the
police pacified the Favela bula's
government built a huge cable car system
transforming the complex into an
international attraction
voters here are looking back at more
prosperous times when money was being
invested in these communities ahead of
the 2016 Olympic Games 50 000 tourists
used to come to this Favela every week
and they would buy arts and crafts and
little stores here they would go to
parties there were bars there were
restaurants there were even hotels to
stay overnight now all of that is long
gone familiar people felt abandoned the
money dried out violence is back
corruption scandals made many lose faith
and politicians to the point that they
voted for bolsonaro who says he'll fight
violence with more violence instead of
investing in education lauriana Souza
was one of the disillusion she had
opened a bar to cater to tourists but
was forced to shut it down
official they closed the cable car from
one day to the next nobody comes here
anymore
she says she'll vote for Lula she hopes
he'll fix the cable car and transform
the slums once again
Rio de Janeiro